thank you right now I would like to
introduce two beautiful actresses
because frankly we're sick and tired of
bringing out all these ugly actresses
ladies and gentlemen please welcome
Carey Mulligan and Zoe Saldana
we get we get the most challenging
entrance that's alright
the roads becoming a successful
filmmaker
sometimes begins by taking the short
route the short film route that is it's
the way many prominent writers and
directors first came to attention short
films are often the first step for
future full-length movies numerous
animated documentary and live-action
feature started out as short it is a
world you might say where people and
ideas begin you know when you're a young
filmmaker nobody believes that you can
make a feature film and the best way to
convince them is to make a short if you
make a short film and the Academy
recognizes you it's the most
unbelievable calling card you can have I
think it's one of the best awards the
academy award gives look back on it now
and I and I still think wow that was
really innovative filmmaking and I'm
still really proud of it and you know
some days when you're making features
you go wow if only I could make a movie
that was as good as my short for me as a
filmmaker having my short when an Oscar
was kind of like getting drafted into
the pros you know one of the things I
like the most about short films they're
short you're kind of like a jewel box of
storytelling my advice to young
filmmakers is the tools never make a
great film it's what you do with the
tools telling a great story entertaining
the audience that's what's gonna win you
an Academy Award
here are the nominees for best animated
short French Roast
Fabricio juba granny Oh Grimm's Sleeping
Beauty
Nikki Phelan and Dara O'Connell the lady
in the Reaper la dama y la muerte Javier
ratio grassy logo Rama Nicolas Merkin a
matter of life and death
Nick Park and the winner is logo Rama
Nicholas Maggie
this is the first Academy Award a
nomination for Nicholas Merkin
good evening
doesn't look like but it's a French film
sorry about the accent so I'm the
producer of the film so I have to thank
the the 3000 non official sponsors that
appears in the film and I have to assure
them that no logos were harmed during
the making of the project this award has
to be shared up with incredible people
who made the film all the team and
especially the three directors that are
with us in the theater tonight from
swallow advocacy and really Kubla you
can close them the directors thanks for
them there we've been working for a very
long time on this film it took like six
years to make this 16 minutes so I hope
to come back here with a long feature
film in about 36 years thank you very
much
here are the nominees for Best
Documentary short China's unnatural
disaster
the tears of Szechuan province Jon
Alpert and Matthew O'Neill the last
campaign of Governor booth Gardner
Daniel young he and Henry Ann's Bukka
the last truck closing of a GM plant
Stephan Bonnar and Julia Reichert music
by prudence
Roger Ross Williams and Elinor Birkett
Rabbit ala Berlin
Bartek Konopka and Anna Vedra and the
winner is music by prudence Roger Ross
Williams and Elinor Burkett
this is the first Academy Award a
nomination for Roger Ross Williams and
Eleanor briquette
oh my god this is amazing
two years ago when I got on an airplane
and went to Zimbabwe I never imagined my
wildest dreams that I'd end up here this
is so exciting man this is so exciting
the classic thing you'll hear a world in
which most of us are told and tell
ourselves that we can't Liana the band
behind this film teaches us that we're
wrong against all odds they did so we
can so the bottom line is to me my role
models and my euros marvelous and energy
chippy were good well the whole rest of
the band and especially prudence and
prudence who is here who is back there
tonight's prudence is here tonight
here are the nominees for Best live
action short the door
Juanita Wilson and James Flynn instead
of abracadabra
Patrick Eklund and Matias field-strip
Kavi Gregg he'll be
miracle fish Luke Doolin and drew Bailey
the new tenants yo Kim bak and TV man
usin and the winner is the new tenants
yo combatants UV magazine
is the first Academy Award and
nomination for yo Kim bak this is the
first Academy Award and second
nomination for T V Magnuson
whoa I just don't know if I should dance
oh if I shoot but it's pretty much
amazing and I just want to say thanks to
everybody who's been on this project and
so actually a beautiful cast and my
producer TV and it's pretty much right I
must say I can't say anything else but I
just want to thank Sam bass be Jackie
Kelman and Ross like I hope you guys is
watching Edelman have a little man
beautiful but anyway thank you very much
for everything
you